plus imposante sur place si l'on
retrouve justement en france beaucoup
d'immigrés venus d'afrique sub
saharienne des maliens des mauritaniens
ou des sénégalais qui s'installent
souvent dans les foyers sonacotra la
solidarité familiale ou villageoise fait
que leur chambre se transforme parfois
en dortoir un sureffectif qui est devenu
un véritable problème dans ses foyers
l'enquêté signée bertrand boyer et jean
christophe duclos samba ne s'en cache
pas depuis neuf ans il héberge
illégalement son jeune frère dans cette
étroite chambre d'un foyer de
travailleurs à peine 9 mètres carrés à
partager à deux pas de toilettes juste
une douche et de matelas
une promiscuité devenu habituel pour les
deux frères franchement c'est difficile
c'est difficile c'est une vie qu'on
approche à deux on n'a pas le choix
quand donc on essaie de s'adapter pour
samba en france depuis 23 ans il était
impossible de refuser d'accueillir son
frère venu comme lui de mauritanie pour
chercher du travail
ça ne se refuse pas culturellement que
de recevoir un membre de sa famille cas
de lui tendre la main
c'était quelque chose solidarité kit
être hors la loi en l'occurrence même si
on est hors la loi
la famille c'est ce qu'on a de plus cher
oronte et moi pour rien au monde je
l'abandonnerai les mais derrière cette
porte à l'étagé supérieur
ce vieil homme nous explique qu'il
cohabite depuis dix ans avec son fils il
attend désormais de rentrer au pays et
la pratique est courante dans ce foyer
où les résidents eux-mêmes estime à près
de 600 le nombre d'occupants pour
seulement 280 places
conséquence de cette suroccupation une
usure accélérée de locaux déjà délaissé
par le gestionnaire et des équipements
collectifs surexploitées cette cuisine
traditionnelle installée à la caf
fournit ainsi plusieurs centaines de
repas par jour dans des conditions
visiblement précaire pour le comité de
résidents qui organisent la vie du foyer
la suroccupation est inévitable car
faute de revenus suffisants et par
manque de logements sociaux les sur
occupants n'ont guère d'autres solutions
cela comptera six pouvoir construire
la solution est rarement possible selon
la sonacotra car en pleine crise du
logement
une face au désintérêt des pouvoirs
publics ce gestionnaire se dit contraint
d'employer des méthodes plus expéditive
nous commençons par m les sur occupants
et surtout ceux qui les accueillent
en face de leurs responsabilités en face
de responsabilité sont des mises en
demeure ce sont des procédures
judiciaires qui peuvent aller jusqu'à la
résiliation du contrat de location et à
l'expulsion mois la sonacotra si jamin
kim est mise en demeure demain pourquoi
parce que j'aime mon frère qui est logé
avec moi j'ai un cousin qui loge avec
moi
lassana contrat de mise en demeure ripon
[ __ ] en prison mais ça ne changera
rien le problème tant que mon frère n'a
pas de logement je ne laisse pas crever
bord que je loge tranquille dans mon lit
comme les autres samba craint désormais
une intervention policière
même si si la très grande majorité des
résidents des papiers en règle
mais dans ce climat tendu il sera sans
doute bien difficile pour le
gestionnaire de faire appliquer la loi
dans un foyer qu'ils négligent abandonné
à l'autogestion des communautés